and getting to and from allegiant
stadium may be a headache on monday
night traffic anchor nate tannebaum has
more on ways to get in and to get out
well something that's been driving
raiders fans crazy
parking at the allegiant stadium home
games in fact the raiders website has
some great information
including a detailed map that pinpoints
the 15 entry gates between russell road
and hacienda the east and west side
drop-off locations the rideshare
drop-off and pickup area north of the
stadium as well as the taxi area procia
and diablo to the west of allegiant
then there are the numerous parking lots
several surrounding allegiant with
others as far away as trop and valley
view
as for which to choose from the website
has links to spot hero and parking.com
where you can find and pay for your spot
and that much cheaper no driving option
the regional transportation commission's
game day express
now you don't have to worry about
writing all that down because we have
the links to those websites in the
online version of this story at
eightnewsnow.com when you click traffic
and driving you crazy